Thank You hymns for sponsoring today's
videos hymns exist to let you guys know
that having skin problems penis problems
and hair loss problems that's not the
weird thing what's weird is when you
don't handle these problems yeah so
through hymns you'll get personalized
recommendations for prescription and
non-prescription products through the
advice of a real-life doctor that's good
Hames also takes your privacy very
seriously and they offer medical grade
solutions so a lot of the times guys
just feel embarrassed like talking to
their doctor in person about hey my hair
it's gone I don't know I don't even know
how to deal with it so hims offers an
embarrassment and hassle-free option of
dealing with it so this is what you get
if you're dealing with some hair loss no
worries because we have a solution for
you we got right here a topical solution
we have a shampoo we got some pills and
you know I have friends who are bald in
and they're not ashamed of it but it's
pretty cool that there's an option like
this where now everything can be done
online and you can save the trip because
cuz you know even if it's not a big deal
for you to go to the doctor or anything
like that just doing it online is just a
lot more convenient because this comes
to you yeah you have to be embarrassed
yeah so make sure to go to for hemes
dot-com /jk news for your comprehensive
hair kits for just $5 the first month $5
for the first month so go ahead and
check out that link in the description
for hems com /jk news and you can get
that hair loss problem handled No enjoy
the episode let's watch the show
[Music]
in paid sick leave news submitted I love
gold and Oreos me too those are the only
ones I eats me - I don't like to talk
about one I'm a fan of all Oreos Orioles
are probably one of the best artificial
cookies nothing I know that does weird
chemical flavor dude yeah the B cookie
sandwich it's like sugar paste inside
these like it's chocolate right opposed
to be chocolate or something right I
think it's made of ribbon fated yeah all
those things used to taste different
back in the day they were actual food
before hmm and then for our generation
it got chemically you know we went to
France they had this American snack
section and one of the malls that we
went and Oreos were on there no like did
you eat it
no anyway we have a real scare there's
probably on the chemical it might be
different though cuz all those snacks
they you know they make them different
out outside they don't just I think they
import them well then it's gonna be the
same yeah University is offering people
3,500 bucks to get sick and stay in the
hotel influenza for testing oh my god
did we get sick with the flu
yep 3500 bucks to get sick I think it
study yep and then like when you start
getting better though they inject you
one more time you're gonna stay sick
what have you got a really good immune
system and then like you get sick but
you get healed real quick yeah you get
to keep in mind I hate being sick they
should just put a bunch of Mexican
people in there see what happened it's
like they're not I don't even get sick
they don't get the flu I know I've only
been the flu once in my life that's
[ __ ] the flu that's crazy
not that I'm proud of that my roommate
he's sick constantly it's it's [ __ ]
hilarious Abe that fool gets sick all
the time like he just wakes up I see him
with a tissue in his face and what
happened he goes there's a cold again
you just had it two weeks ago what the
[ __ ] happened I never get into you do
one healthy ass [ __ ] no so I know dude
could you stop losing weight please I'm
about to become the fat guy and it's
driving me [ __ ] crazy he's got a walk
back yeah baby you look so good
like three weeks and all just like it's
a drastic difference that hard part now
though like once you lose that you're
plateauing yeah that I lost like thirty
five pounds right now and now it's
getting difficult
come on Thursdays and Tuesdays and
Wednesdays and Mondays and Fridays
[Laughter]
that's it I just like that whole wait
for anything like scares the [ __ ] out of
me I'm a lyft smart seven that's great
yeah did I see you on Instagram doing
that and I'm like this looks miserable
and you're like I am miserable he's like
you have to smile while you do what you
hate and I'm like no I don't want to do
that he's very honest that's what I like
about his fitness I like it no one
really likes training it's all food
though man like I detained a lot of the
foods that I eat more like camping bro
yeah you know that day and a half that
we were there we were going ham dude I
thought they'd gained eight pounds
oh because also because I didn't [ __ ]
very well oh and then after I took like
three shits I went back down to like -
220 - I love it you weigh yourself after
you [ __ ]
you're obsessed good [ __ ] five pounds
is it only because like if I know how
hard it is to lose the weight if you
gain it it's it's very mentally
defeating because if you gained eight
pounds that's gonna take me another like
two three weeks to lose oh [ __ ] I gotta
get back on it off his water Dookie it
was just all Dookie salt and water we
ain't good though we had a girl waffles
with Portuguese sausage and scrambled
eggs for breakfast ribeye steaks for
dinner we had like asparagus I put with
butter on there like also so good how
did that was probably butter yeah
there's the only way to use barriers
well yeah just with man or else how the
salt gonna stick that's bear yes camping
is fun what it was is out of the love
Hotel influence what's hotel st. Louis
University is funding this whole thing
and so they're trying to get people 24
guests to check into this 24 room hotel
that they've transformed into a research
center and they want people to stay
there for 10 days they'll be getting
paid $3,500 they'll have access to TV
Internet in their own private bathroom
that's pretty good for ten days
but they just bored all day sick trying
to recover and [ __ ] they're gonna be
injecting like some people with the
placebo flu vaccine I hope I get that
one we're not injecting they're gonna be
with the fake the fake sickness or it's
all about the cure everyone stay secure
here not what the real cure they're
gonna get the flu through the nasal
spray let me get the flu the cure the
treatment they're saying that they're
gonna they're gonna give them the are
gonna get them sick
yeah isn't there like a new form of flu
that's really devastating or something
like yeah it's the new strains pretty
rockin on post [ __ ] yeah last year some
people died yeah I think someone in
California died from it god damn yeah
people die every year but this year has
been especially severe yeah and then
there's like certain flu strains that
are resistant to the medicine that's why
every single year they have to come up
with a new one oh my god I never get a
flu shot
dude [ __ ] the flu shot the only year I
got a flu shot is when I got the [ __ ]
meat me too I got it like two weeks
later I was like are you kidding me if
you're about to have a kid they're gonna
keep till you get the flu shot get the
flu shot [ __ ] you I'm not gonna [ __ ] a
flu shot [ __ ] that's sick and it's that
weird strain or whatever then you're
you're putting your kid in danger but
see a doctor watch this right now is
like you can't get the flu from a flu
shot I know that's the meme do but I
swear to God I did I did to know you had
the flu already in your system Tom I
know what's [ __ ] up like I know a lot
of a lot of my friends who have kids
right now their kids don't get sick
right but the parents get sick because
the kids keep touching all these other
[ __ ] kids and they bring it home and
so the parents are always [ __ ] up like
my friends to him he got the [ __ ]
food three times already
from his [ __ ] coupons when you're the
kid like you you like you're like you're
three years old and you put your hand
your friends mouth of course they get
sick you gotta boil those [ __ ] kids
man he always get sick he's the one
that's the most ignorant like the filter
yeah but it's always Isaac getting him
sick exactly time it's funny cause you
got the strong genes that either
probably has a strong genes and he has a
weak teens in the valley
you know it's crazy whatever Isaac at
this last time was [ __ ] crazy cuz PC
didn't get sick at all and I got sick
right before we left we caught the
Cantonese flu that's why immunity for it
mucus feel like like flying we look at
soy sauce turn it into bok choy these
soy sauce and stir fry yeah I guess
cause the bird flu damn hard to keep
kids clean though man isn't damn you're
impossible
yeah cuz it's hard to keep me clean as
an adult so you have to be mindful to
wash their hands all the time you know
kids they only smell like [ __ ]
god damn it they do that pack sweat and
[ __ ] spit that's what they smell like
but what baby smells so [ __ ] baby it
smell like Dookie sometimes if I could
have a candle that was baby smell candle
like the smell of a baby's head candle I
would [ __ ] get that candle baby the
smell of a baby's has oh good oh yeah
the baby's head right that soft skin
smell yeah I could eat a baby I really
could hell yeah when he was first born
it smell like better no yeah it was
great no he smells like baby if he got
all the hormones out that hella harmless
wants my your baby will come over all
right thank you know my come on where's
my your baby really now we're good mama
come on moving oh really where you going
oh great traitor yeah so there's all
these volunteers trying to sign up to
get that money but then they're gonna be
getting fixed so it's 3,500 for ten days
yeah that's pretty good are they
guaranteed to be like cured at the end
the day no they come out all [ __ ] up I
mean who knows cuz they're gonna be
testing on these new vaccines oh is
pretty fun that's [ __ ] bomb yeah and
if you're gonna if they're gonna
guarantee that you're gonna live and
you're gonna be within a hospital you'll
be pretty funny
dude GrubHub drivers are watching this
right now boiling what the [ __ ] am i
doing no cuz then after you get it you
might get stronger oh yeah do you want
to get as many like sick things as
possible so you could be stronger again
these drivers are gonna be studying for
this duty you don't have to drive your
car a bunch of miles around and pick
people up and like all [ __ ] you just
have to sit there with the flu that's
tight I might get rekt - you guys ever
get the flu where it's like it's [ __ ]
hot as [ __ ] and then you get [ __ ]
and then you [ __ ] put all these
blankets light starts sweating it hot
again you lads when I take the flu
you're talking about it like it's a
woman I love it it's crazy because you
can't sleep on the fluke which is like
[ __ ] your body aches from yeah just
like tossing and turning because the
nighttime theraflu knocks you though
yeah do that so that's like benadryl
dude yeah I like that bin and but night
like I I'm not really like so set to bow
to a lot of like medications that knock
you out aside for my some of the
hardcore [ __ ] but theraflu is one of
those things if I take the nighttime one
I'm out in an hour easy and I won't wake
up until like next you don't take sure
one hour
yes suck a sleepy they changed the
formula though so I haven't been sick
like had a flu in a while but I heard
they they changed that [ __ ] cuz they
were like in trouble for some drug [ __ ]
no públicas was too harsh it was too
good yeah I've had like some of the
worst like recently uber experiences
like I could feel like the uber drivers
are getting weirder and we're not doing
a good job at like filtering them cuz I
like this one girl recently who was like
from East LA scared the [ __ ] [ __ ] out
of me dude because her bad drivers right
she is the worst driver ever dude we
almost got t-boned like twice because
she [ __ ] passed up two stop signs
cuz she was so busy talking to me and
well she wasn't right right up oh my god
it sounds like part like that was the
first time I had to write a bad review
because I was afraid to kill somebody
yeah because she's insane but she was
talking about some like very
inappropriate [ __ ] like it's like to me
it's hilarious yeah we just talking
about like religion and like all this
other stuff like I didn't even know her
she's yeah like I don't give a [ __ ] if
you like you could believe whatever you
want but my [ __ ] kids they're not
gonna grow to be the [ __ ] rapist and
murderer [ __ ] and I'm like hey my name
is David we get into this conversation
dude you should just keep missing all my
exits I was like oh [ __ ] I was in the
car with a bad driver as well but he was
playing a [ __ ] Jeff Dunham CD and I
was like yo dude I don't even care
here's the bad driver
just don't play that [ __ ] Jeff like
that was my whole review I'm like no
just don't do it man
everyone likes Jeff Dunham okay he's a
young guy that has like singing in his
act he's the puppet guy
oh god knows puppet yeah this is another
guy who had like he had like under glows
and like LED lights are on his whole car
I had it on my Instagram story cuz I
thought it was gonna die because he was
speeding and on the freeway he had all
the windows down oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] didn't
speak English so I was fun alright and
he passed by exit by two exits
cuz he's too into the music me and Nicky
had a guy like that he had a little
disco ball on a car and neon everywhere
and the whole time I was just talking
him about how much I love to smash [ __ ]
because he's one of those guys you know
to be with him and he was giving me like
a lot was it oh yeah I love to beat a
[ __ ] up and I'm like oh yeah I love to
just [ __ ] wreck a [ __ ] and [ __ ] or
Nicky's just like vlogging it laughing
that's dull guys like cuz you know when
you're in you know you're when you're
close to one of those guys like that's
that's the move yeah play that play that
dip
[Music]